[Music]
welcome to iron Lords podcast
and we are live right Lord podcast Lords
a game with net I am Lord kognito who is
this fine gentleman in the realm today
thank you I'm Eric Frandsen community
marketing manager for Eline media nice
nice ilan media and we're here to
discuss this game this beyondblue what
can you tell us about beyond blue so
beyond blue is a narrative driven
underwater exploration game you play as
Mariah who sent to the South China Sea
the western Pacific to explore some
unusual biological activity the cool
thing is it's all based on real science
or we're bbc's blue planet 2 team of
scientists among other folks to advise
us on the project and get all the
details right Wow so give us all the
footage from the series that you will
that we've cut into what we're calling
ocean insights ok a little mini
documentaries the O unlock as you play
the game we have the BBC official cosine
Y so this is big so let's get right into
this game yeah sync to the people with
it what they want to see so right now
again I'm seeing first of all the engine
the game looks beautiful let's just
let's get that right off the tie the
game looks absolutely fantastic ok we're
starting right into the gameplay so
what's going on now give us a background
narrative Lee what's happening
absolutely so this is the first dive in
the whole game and
I'll give you a little teaser into the
story the central kind of animal
characters are a pod of sperm whales
okay and so you're doing some exploring
but you're also gonna be encountering
some of these and you know beautiful
creatures throughout this environment
they looks outstanding just to scope
with deceit you got there you go forget
enough scandal what's going on here so
you're looking for the devil right there
I think it's up above you for the devil
ray
and so he's scanning so this is one of
the primary mechanics of the game you're
also using this to train your AI systems
to recognize creatures and kind of
there's a little bit of collect
collectibles as well you kind of
scanning various creatures that you all
go check out a little bit later sort of
purpose right now with opal opal second
it explores already gathering data kind
of a kind of a phase kind of way yeah
yeah and a story really at the center so
the story is kind of driving a lot of
this forward and then you know kind of
everything from you know the creatures
you're encountering to the relationships
you have with your crew and even your
interpersonal relationships well because
you know when talking to scientists we
we learned so much about kind of what it
really means to be an ocean scientists
and the the challenges in day-to-day you
know so Danis ad the ocean scientist
simulator dare to say not too bad I like
it we're gonna run with it did so again
back to those graphics I can't get over
what engine are we using here this is
unity building lesson this is amazing
okay so give me going on right now as
far as like maybe uh can we give us like
maybe resolutions and we're running and
things of that nature
yep so
and 1080p and we go 30 frames 60 frame
what are we looking at right now
question I don't actually know often but
everything I've seen so far has been 60
okay so what's going on right hey what's
what's the Lord PD do we having to do
right here no this year is a
communications buoy so if you pull this
up it'll be a little minigame you're
gonna triangulate the sounds of some of
the creatures in the environment and
that will unlock the waypoints so I'll
add some of the creatures so you're
gonna it's not gonna come through in the
video but you'll have some audio cues
it's like a game of hot and cold so you
can kind of see the bars getting bigger
right right right and then you're gonna
punch in and it'll unlock a waypoint
you're really and
I would say probably stay zoomed out
it's a little bit more okay it's a
little bit easier to pin it down there
there you go so there's one there's
gonna be two more so there's one more to
your right yep
I don't even see it get hot it's like he
gave a hot hot cold yeah there it is and
then there's one more to your left
little ways over
hey nice nice now they've got three
waypoints that you can explore in any
order you want no I'm sort of ask you
about that mechanic it but specifically
sure you don't obviously we're trying to
find things out we'll rumble support
because it involved with that is that
kind of something you make think about
it was a good question not that I'm
aware of but that's a cool idea
idiots like me that wouldn't find that I
would need Roman support I was just
thinking about your tea party other
people for the challenge people for the
challenge people so we've got to
continue so let's go to adapt yep so now
he's a kind of looking for this part of
Domino the scan of the dolphins here so
engaging the scanner and doing a scan
here and so again this is kind of
telling your system
you know hey these are bottlenose
dolphins stand so it is they as we
acquire more creatures more different
you know marine life things that nature
is that how we unlock the story beats is
that how we eventually progress things
which are cruel and the other sciences
that as well as some of the dialogue
choices that you'll make so once you're
out of the water in this diet we're
gonna you're gonna retreat to your sub
and that's where you'll actually really
communicate so you're talking to your
team here right but when you really sit
down and kind of talk about what's going
on make some of those choices
that'll be what's on the sub main kind
of really push that well what do we look
at that what are two questions what do
we look at that level structure wise as
far as levels and then also obviously
the old BB c--'s there behind it you
know what what what BIG's are you kind
of not allowed to do get up one day I'm
not seeing is like doesn't seem like
things are threatening anyone like I'm
not seeing that I mean they're in danger
so to speak yeah so as far as the levels
go I would say it's a semi-open world so
it's on a truly open world where you can
go anywhere but they are big areas you
can explore freely which kind of brings
us into the next point which is you're
not in any danger you're not managing
resources right there's not combat right
because the show I'm not seeing the
shocks coming up as well
wanted to go for an immersive kind of
you know really the the wonder of the
ocean and not you know folks would be
like I could just distress yeah I can
jump in there I could find my ocean okay
I get it that like a pop on wildlife I
get it now I'm getting the vibes I'm
understanding and it's worth noting she
doesn't have an air tank you may have
noticed yes so it's set in the near
future
okay so there's a little bit of
Technology conceits in this game so you
know rebreather other things like that
no does she get other equipment the
things that I need you to kind of
enhance this journey well these are
basic skill sets as far as how the
journeys gonna play out there isn't a
skill tree but you will be so in the
next dive you get ace what's he called
the Panta drone so did you zoom scanning
who where you're kind of doing orbital
scans of the creatures a little bit more
in depth so again this is another phase
right now what's going on right now with
this favors yep so now there's gonna be
some more sound so was that sounded I
break something there's some sounds
there's a little bit of mystery and kind
of some of these threads so as I
mentioned with the whales and with some
other creatures who'd be following some
threads of a little bit of mystery some
drama
okay so drama drama going on we take
this story in the game seriously I mean
the actual creatures are well they look
phenomenal and again it'd be a little
bit more detail as far out again the
BBC's involvement with the assets and
things that you're able to use and
implement in the game sure so I should
contextualize how we even connected with
them in the first place so after our
last game never alone
if you're familiar with that about a
girl and her Fox in Alaska it was an
atmospheric platforming game that we
made in partnership with the Inupiat
people to tell one of their oldest folk
stories so we were fortunate enough to
win a BAFTA for that guy oh wow
congratulation that's we've got going to
gloss over that him that's bathtub
this is royalty continued and so that
brought us to their attention one of the
things they really liked in particular
was what we called cultural insights
that you unlock by playing the game and
so we we brought that into this game
with an ocean insights with the footage
that you unlock as you play and so that
was how they came through in a big way
with giving us all the footage and
access to scientists that were long
project to advances you know using that
footage in the documentary they also
block in the game and just generally
being a great partner that is pretty
awesome that looks good oh that it looks
good on the resume so how's it feeling
pity that you can get your swim or when
you get your deep cadaver yeah it's
really it's immersive like huh I'm not
the type of person that's gonna sit like
you know
I don't normally a hundred folks on the
game yeah but I am focusing on this it's
just the beauty of the game itself in
and if you see how the movement in the
water and even even to the point of like
just the changing of the lights on the
stun the suit itself and and the dive
and the you guys can't hear but the
sounds yeah it's so beautiful
it sounds like you are swimming next to
the fish right next to a whale right now
a dolphin last couple of questions that
were to ask so again how far we in
development you know I'm saying as far
as let's get into that we are getting
very close so we're not a position to
announce the release date but it is darn
soon that darn soon y'all now that's the
technical talk so good as far as now
platforms because in my opinion you
could have fooled me this almost look
like a next-gen
and of a game and you know that the new
consoles are coming you know so first of
all PC start first four simultaneous BCE
console releases simultaneous PC and
console so PC we have a page up on Steam
now but we're gonna be targeting other
PC platform or platforms as well and
then Xbox Playstation switch should be
coming a little bit later wait a mixed
up the presses
i'ma switch biased yeah um did you say
this amazing-looking game from the unity
can be brought down to the switch again
it could it be could it be converted
such graphical fidelity yes I just need
you to say it so it's good anyway but
that's awesome no seriously because a
lot of times you know it shows the
scalability of the engine and a lot of
people don't realize that that that's an
awesome feature so that people will
switch orders don't miss out
yeah and again if you want to get this
one to go get you a little explanation
on it has that kind of thing I want to
make an underwater case so you can play
this underwater so look you heard it
here first
beyondblue I love podcaster probably
definitely very unique concept very
educational informative and what else
can you talk to telling people before we
go
you know one of our goals as a company
is impact and so we hope that this game
will cause more people to be very
engaged and excited about the ocean as
excited as we are and so it's coming
soon okay so let me check it out and
check it out
I love podcast Lords of gaming net
signing out
[Music]